so what do you say to filmmakers who
assume they have an audience we hear
from so many people that submit their
films for our interactive oh I can pack
the house and it's going to be no
problem but then they don't work in
building it and then they're deflated in
their egos or bruise because they have
no audience for their film what do you
say to those filmmakers yeah so
sometimes it's a content problem
sometimes it's a you know lack of effort
or maybe not a lack of effort but the
wrong I firm and so you know I learned
from the experience don't give up I mean
very few people are successful on their
first time or even on or percent of the
time so it's important to still to learn
from your mistakes and understand what
people are doing well and what might
work for your filming it sounded yeah
unfortunately it's not formulates not
one-size-fits-all so you have to
understand what works for your
particular concept for your film for
your actors for your idea and go out
there and capitalize on that and if it
doesn't work get up you know it's a fall
down seven times get update what do you
think is the right effort and what's the
one that might be too bad if a question
but just you again I think it depends on
your film in your project I think you
have to define the audience as much as
we want to be creative and you know it's
more of a art than it is a science I
think we have to think from that from at
the very beginning who's our audience
who are we going to reach and almost
tailor your career your product to fit
those needs in to resonate with that
audience and have the audience in mind
the entire way throughout the product
and like get burns and Kevin Smith they
do really good job at interacting with
their audience throughout the whole
process and it gives them a sense of
ownership and excitement to see it when
it comes out
trying some new stuff like that we now
have the tools and